ربما القصف الاكثر عنفا كما تحدث الزميل
اسماعيل والقصف الاكثر كثافه هو مركز في
مدينه خان يونس ومنذ بدات العمليه
العسكريه في مدينه خانيونس خاصه في
المناطق الغربيه نحن نتحدث عن انخفاض حده
الغارات في مناطق مختلفه من قطاع غزه
وتركزت في مدينه خانيونس خاصه في المناطق
الغربيه وعلى مستشفى ومحيط مستشفى ناصر
ومحيط مستشفى الامل في خانيونس وما زال
مستشفى ناصر في خانيونس محاصر ما زالت
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه تحذر من كارثه
صحيه في مستشفى ناصر من جراء استمرار هذا
الحصار وجراء استمرار اطلاق النار و وصول
الشداء الى مستشفى ناصر ومقاومات الحياه
في المستشفى مثل خزانات المياه لكن ما
زالت الغارات ايضا في مناطق مختلفه من
قطاع غزه حيث يقصف الجيش الاسرائيلي في
بيت لاهيه حيث ابلغ شهود عيان عن انفجارات
ناجمه عن قصف مدفعي على ما يبدو في منطقه
بيت لاهيه ايضا القصف المدفعي مستمر في
المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه غزه قصفت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ايضا منزلا في حيت تل
الهواء في مدينه غزه كذلك كان هناك غارات
على مخيم النصيرات خاصه في المناطق
الشماليه لمخيم النصيرات يسمع ما بين
الفينه والاخرى اصوات قصف مدفعي على هذا
المخيم ايضا الدبابات الاسرائيليه مازالت
متواجده على الحدود الشرقيه لقطاع غزه
خاصه في المنطقه الوسطى مخيم مخيم البريج
ومخيم المغاز مازالا يتعرضان الى قصف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ما بين فينه واخرى
كذلك المناطق الشرقيه لدين البلح التي
تتعرض ايضا هي الاخرى الى قصف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه لكن كما قلنا القصف الاكثر
حده والقصف الاكثر عنفا هو في مدينه
خانيونس خاصه في المناطق الغربيه للمدينه
مدينه رفح ايضا خاصه المناطق الشرقيه
لمدينه رفح تتعرض هي الاخرى ما بين فينه
واخرى الى قصف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه و
الغارات متفرقه ما بين غارات من الجو
والقصف المدفعي لكن الاوضاع الانسانيه
ربما هي التحدي الابرز الان للسكان السكان
كانوا يتعرضون الى قصف اسرائيلي الان
المعركه منصبه على حمايه الاطفال وتوفير
الدفئ لهؤلاء الاطفال خاصه النازحين من
مدينه خانيونس الذين لا يتوفر لهم ماوى في
مدينه رفح اغلب السكان الان يتوجهون الى
منطقه المواصي في رفح المناطق الغربيه
وايضا الى مدينه رفح باحيائها المختلفه
وكل هذه الاحياء تتعرض الى احوال جويه
سيئه وبالتالي الناس باتت في امام تحدي
كبير وامام معركه جديده هي معركه الاحوال
الجويه اذا كانت هناك امطار اذا كانت هناك
رياح فهم امام تحدي لعدم اقتلاع الخيام من
مكانها وايضا لعدم غرق هذه الخيام بمياه
الامطار وبالتالي التحدي الاكبر الان هو
توفير الدفئ هو توفير الغذاء هو توفير
المياه في ظل احوال جويه سيئه في ظل ايضا
نقص حاد في هذه في هذا الغذاء هذا الغذاء
وهذه المياه وهذا الدواء نحن نتحدث عن
مليون و300 ال نسمه متواجدين في رفح بعدما
كان عدد سكان مدينه رفح 300000 نسمه بعدما
كان يتوجه الى المستشفى 40 الى 50 حاله
اليوم في هذا المستشفى مستشفى الكويت 1500
حاله يوميا 500 حاله هم من الاطفال من
جراء البرد القارس من جراء الامراض
المعديه من جراء الامراض المعويه من جراء
الامراض الجلديه المنتشره الاوبئه منتشره
بشكل كبير في مخيمات اللاجئين والنازحين
الفلسطينيين وبالتالي الاوضاع صعبه وتوفير
اي شيء هو مهمه صعبه بل تكاد تكون مستحيله
في ظل هذه الظروف